economic inactivity is the rather
clinical catch-all term for a crucial
issue it means anyone of working age
that's 16 to 64 who's not in a job or
looking for one and there are currently
8.8 million people who fit that
description for all sorts of reasons two
million students a million are early
retirees more than 1.6 million are not
working because they're looking after
family or home but the biggest group of
these ones the light blue line long term
sickness 2.53 million people as of
February and all time high now we can
take a closer look at the trend if we
look at what's happened since the
pandemic the blue line is the increase
in inactivity since 2020 at its peak
more than 600 000 more people out of
work than before the pandemic it's
coming down larger students move into
employment but the age profile is
interesting the red bars here are 50 to
64 year olds and look they make up
almost three quarters of the newly
inactive now we know some of them took
early retirement but the more
significant trend is long-term sickness
now we can see it here now now the red
lines represent long-term sickness you
can see it Rose as the pandemic goes on
people fall out of work they can't get
back in and now they essentially make up
all of the newly inactive outside the
workplace now if we come back to the
bigger picture there's another number
worth considering that's NHS waiting
lists of routine procedures got the
total at the top the sick down here the
Red Line This is the rise in people
waiting for treatments not helped by
industrial action now we can't draw a
direct link between the long-term
sickness and inactivity it was a vivid
demonstration of the pressure on the NHS
that may be feeding a cycle of
inactivity and all of this has
consequences there are still fewer
people in work than before covid more
than a million unfilled vacancies and
that limits the capacity for growth and
ultimately generating tax revenue to
fund the NHS the chancellor says
economic inactivity is a priority but
solving it looks like a full-time job